not gonna lie you couldn't approach me
and me ask your name and you say dog
yeah what are you saying because I've
been thinking I would I I would want to
laugh but I don't know whether it's a
laugh or not
I'd question myself in like what did I
ask you yes
I mean you know when you start looking
through something because in your head
you're doing backflips you think what
did I ask what did I asked
[Music]
cool guys what's good what's good we're
back we're back with another Banger as
per
um we've again got another special guest
we have in the house today we're doing
this a little bit more regular degular
um so anyone that we invite should be
like entirely honored
um whether this one is today or not I
don't even know
um but what I like to do before
we've hand over to the guest I like to
give a little introduction for everyone
that we invite into the studio so this
person here not gonna lie the
introduction is not as easy as the other
ones I don't really notice brother
ladder yeah I don't really know this
brother he's a one of the funniest guys
around one of one of these yeah yeah one
of definitely one of
um it's not Gass it it's definitely one
of um but now this guy
I like this guy a lot actually he's very
cool the content is good
um he shows a lot of wit and
intelligence in his content which is
actually very difficult to do well and
do consistently and I think people sleep
on it and I don't think he actually gets
the props for it
as he deserves facts
um
and yeah man he's a cool guy what else
can I say he responds when I message him
which is cute facts
um yeah the first time I met him yeah
the first time I met he was wearing the
same kicks as me and didn't even cost me
or anything yeah he's wearing the exact
same kicks humbling I'm pretty sure you
were wearing a sex scene I was living
um and as soon as we invited him on he
was like gang I'm there he arrived
pretty much on time as far as black
people go
um I think it was like seven minutes
late yeah yeah Sensational and he called
me to let me know he's going to be like
bro he said the exact minute he was
going to get here man unbelievable stuff
we don't give courtesies like that
um but anyway guys
without any further Ado we're very very
honored to have him here today we're
going to pass you over to the one and
only
darkest human let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
this might be the most nervous I've been
for sure
you notice I watch you guys and I'm a
fan and now I'm here
that's never happened before yes
no I'm good man yeah nothing to complain
about I'm all good I feel good nice yeah
excited happy to have you here man
always bro this has been a long time
coming obviously like James said we met
for the first time at an event was it
was it this year was it like honestly
probably last year but it was last year
we met an event last year late last year
and it was literally we bumped each
other and it was just all love yeah we
hadn't met each other before we had a
message each other before and it was
just genuine love I remember just
hugging you and I was like bro I've
hugged this brother before
that's what it felt like like I felt
like I met him before because everything
you post and everything you do like is
so
it's so unique and it's so natural to
you I just like James said I don't know
how you're not further than you are like
you you need to be bigger than you are
do you know what I mean it's it's just
crazy
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for coming today and thank you
for for watching us man
um
that's super nice
um right so
we do when we have guests on now and
again I have a little Icebreaker so we
asked the fans to like just cook you for
a bit just for a little bit I hate this
no because I saw I saw what happened to
Madame Joyce oh yeah yeah she she
handled it really well she did I might
not give you the same reaction that's
fine so what we're gonna have to do just
um
yeah just don't laugh then just just
okay
yeah yeah [__] yeah and ahead of time
this is not how we feel about you yeah I
understand it's important to note this
is not how we feel about you relax and
this is not stuff and this I don't know
if it's how they feel about you they
just they were asked to cook you know
there's the joke and then there's
delivery the joke's not you but the way
you deliver it is just make sure it's
clean and normal and you didn't yeah I
mean
I'm not gonna lie the way through I
deliver stuff
it's officially it's like he came up
with it
all right bet
um
that's actually dread all right cool
right so how quickly guys um this cop
says Don Julio there's volvic limb in
the lamb oh right yes
[Music]
um that is this in here yeah yeah yeah
hit me
um right cool you want to start go
girlfriend go figure no you mean I want
to work my way up to him
right
so right
roasting darkest manual yeah take one
fam first one of the jump sombre said
look looks like when you drop a lolly on
the carpet
that made me dizzy it looks like when
you drop a lolly on the carpet bro I'd
appreciate is how fast we'd move on from
that joke sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry no okay that's a good one all
right phase you up guys
[Laughter]
at least it will never go broke he could
rent that forehead out as a billboard
for adverts okay oh oh okay fair enough
fair enough that's true didn't kill me
yeah it's just those ones yeah that's
called Scott but it's gone all right
someone put
he's a stunt double for midnight
oh so with midnight I feel it oh okay
fine I'll come all right you're doing
well bro okay
you ready yeah you're gone
look at me bro
all right he looks like someone deep
fried at Damon Wayans
[Laughter]
that's red but that's yeah that's a
handsome bread like Damon Wayans that's
a hazard
stop bro stop so stop fam someone jumped
in and said I don't know which is
blacker his skin or his gums [__] off
[Laughter]
no don't don't do that nope no no no
oh my god oh bro I told you it's not how
we feel and it's not how they feel
they're just saying stuff his head is so
big whenever he ties his shoelace he
falls forward I heard that's not the
first first I know I do feel like a bit
off balance
Afghanistan
someone said we got stuff for that kind
of stuff
bro I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry it's nearly
over it is nearly over all right he
looks like he bites people when he gets
excited I do
yeah I do like listen I especially here
he looks like he was one of those kids
who showed Bare Bum while pissing in
Primary School
Charles's ankles
right I've got one more I'm not even
gonna look bro you're making me feel
better now
right last one real quick looks like
it's baby teeth
oh my God ah if you draw a h on his
forehead a chopper will land on it
all right please that's the last one
that's awesome
that's the last one oh bro you feel
relaxed I feel like I'm here now I feel
like it's only up from here bro it
literally is only up so we're in for a
good episode it is we might I've heard
with what I've heard like see what I'm
saying to you like you know I think the
worst one I've heard it's just a simple
one I showed my head to someone and they
were like oh when
when
bro I bro when like was that them
concerned ones oh
damn bro yeah
sorry sorry Gmail when you're creaming
your face where do you stop like all of
these yeah yeah the thing is because
I've seen quite a few of them
[Applause]
so where does your face oh
when you're cream in your face when do
you stop
nah bro I have to get one more round
someone said they don't know whether you
decide to use uh shower gel or Head and
Shoulders that's straight because they
don't know yeah yeah I still have a
scalp so I still have that stuff oh [__]
man bro yeah um yeah you've been cooked
in the past like I've seen obviously
when you get with chunks Philly and all
Harry and them like everyone Cooks each
other so I've seen quite a few of the
ones that your ones are good though bro
no you have to fight back yeah yeah yeah
you're venomous that's all I know you
you've been through the ringer bro yeah
you've learned to defend yourself you've
got a sharp time yeah
[Laughter]
all right cool so let me calm down oh
God thank you for that intro thank you
so much for that bro it was hilarious
right so what we're going to do now this
is the part where we I'm sorry I'm sorry
you know by the end of this I want you
guys to say yo you're the best guess
we've ever had gang literally that's my
aim well we're warming up to it I'm
gonna give you like bread
all right bro
all right I'm susceptible bro I'm not
gonna lie I'm susceptor bags um right
cool so this is the part where
what we like to do is we call it like
origin story here so this is it actually
works quite well for you because perfect
yeah I don't know you that well
whatsoever yeah
um
so this is just from like jump this is
from childhood
to
start in filming I know you had like
also like a very weird entry as a
Creator
um
and then how we got here today yeah so
if you had to leave this off bro um
number one question number one is prior
to darkest man yeah what were you like
as a child or like as a human being
prior to like that's a genuine question
so like apart from like prior to the
darkest man Persona yeah what would you
say you were like
okay I want to say in terms of humor and
um the things I find silly and all that
stuff obviously as you grow up some
things get different like yes you lose
interest like things but in terms of
Banner
always been the same okay like literally
I don't I don't try to be a different
kind of funny or or be a different kind
of person on camera on camera off camera
it's basically I'm I'd like to believe
I'm the same person okay I don't put on
I wouldn't say I put on act but before
darkest I was um I was very childish
okay I was way more childish I didn't
really care about what I said and um I
don't really care about repercussions it
was just whatever came to my head I'll
just say okay yeah you can see like if
you kind of see that in me which is I
say the most random [__] till today but
I think it's a bit more controlled now
okay I'm saying but um in terms of the
stupid show I used to say that's that
stayed the same cool yeah fair enough
and prior to again prior to darkest man
on like this career path what was the
first job you had
um the first job I had lasted two months
literally it was literally just two
months so I went I went from school to
UNI left uni
I went to Wolverhampton
and during that year I lived in
Birmingham because Birmingham was 100
like 45 minutes okay okay tuna bro so I
lived in Birmingham for a year and then
also I was going to University of
Hampton and then um after that I
realized uni won't really for me I
didn't like it what do you try and study
or what did you do business business I
like the business side of things I just
didn't like the accounting side of
things like that stuff and um yeah and I
I CL I'm not really an exam guy I don't
like exams bro I don't like the idea of
you have to revise all year and that one
piece of paper determines how hard you
work yeah you could be nervous like
shivering doesn't mean I don't think I
don't really think it measures
intelligence so I just I don't really
like exams and stuff so I thought the
score really for me so I left and then
um when I left I didn't really have a
plan I just thought I don't want to do
this but I didn't really tell myself oh
I can do this so I think I was a problem
I was during the ages of 18 19 I was a
problem especially for my mum and a
couple family members because obviously
when you're not doing anything you
become a burden to other people so
chunks will tell you that for a fact and
then so yeah I was just sort of living
off my mum a couple of friends even I
was living with chunks living off him as
well and this is when he wasn't really
popping on YouTube he was working a
part-time job to support YouTube yeah so
obviously
um so I'll just be like that in the
house
literally 18 years
damn yeah
how old are you that I think I was I
want to say
um 10. he's all the evil chunks he's
older than me by ear okay
I'm 26. oh damn yeah I thought you were
older well yeah that's the fair
assumption I mean it's fair enough yeah
um enough
yeah yeah we'll get to that we'll
definitely
keep your plugs to yourself bro
um
okay cool we're in the house yeah so you
dropped out after one year at Uni yeah
after one year you know I said it's not
for me then my mom um was like yo
obviously like I've had enough you can't
live with me no more send me off to my
dad my dad's in Oman okay
that's where he lives in it okay so send
me off to live with him obviously she
tried to she gave me the the koalas well
you're gonna leave you're gonna come
back in two weeks oh Jesus two weeks
later I'm just like well come on I
haven't packed it no updates I knew it
was done it was a it was one of them
ones so obviously just end up staying
with my dad and then I was just that
whole time I was with my dad I was just
trying to find a way back I was just
trying to yeah I was trying to apologize
I promise I changed but I have this I'm
doing this like just send me back like
because everyone else speaks Arabic man
and I'm like I can't I don't want to
have to fit into a new culture and a new
lifestyle at the age of 19. like I've
already understood how this place works
I was like let me just stay there I
understand my mistakes now I promise
won't do it again like cool so no more
after like eight months after like eight
months and then because my mom wasn't
having it my mum wasn't average like yo
like you've been saying You're Gonna
Change Change blah blah blah but you
haven't changed obviously
obviously like
um she gave in eventually and she let me
come back
um she gave me a house key she was just
like yo you're gonna be living with me
you're gonna do this this she didn't
tell me what to do in my life she just
said you're not like come and come and
staying out late all of this stuff
making me worry about you all that stuff
yeah that's all got to stop yeah which
I'm saying too and you have to I have to
see you being productive with doing
something yeah yeah so at that point I
was like okay cool
I don't have a YouTube channel
um but people still knew who I was from
chunks's videos okay so I went to Trunks
and I was like yo I want to start
Channel like a lot of people have
started like I think it's time to and he
was like cool I mean I didn't have a
laptop I didn't have camera I didn't
have no fans at the time in it so I
thought can I use yours like while I'm
doing this he was like yeah of course
bro no problem he's my brother at the
end of the day in it so so he made the
channel for me I remember it took off
straight away because a lot of people
already knew how I was so I remember I
got like 10K in four hours
that's [__] annoying I'm gonna lie to
you it's annoying what year was this
this was 2017.
yeah yeah
[Applause]
and then I remember waking up after that
four hours and I was like oh [__] then I
went to out to dinner with my friends
and then came home went to sleep woke up
20K
and then um yeah I think I just I don't
want to say I stay consistent but I
think I stay consistent in making
appearances whether it was on my Channel
or chunkses or beta squad or other other
companies that you don't want to plug
yeah yeah so like obviously I was with
foot Asylum yeah and then
so yeah so it's literally just I just
kept I think I wasn't really consistent
on my own channel but I'd like to
believe I was consistent on being a
feature yeah that's kind of yeah that
kind of made me like who I am today okay
okay and how do you feel like
obviously making that transition
into being a creator
at first was obviously like you said was
a way for you to just be productive
um
and whereas most people like obviously
would sit there and be like
this is why I find it like fascinating
to talk about because obviously most
people who start YouTube YouTube
channels would just be like oh bro like
either they're like mad creative or they
just see it as like money money money
money money where's yours you're coming
up we're seeing
the end not the end product but you can
see an example of like what it actually
looks like and you just need something
to do and all of a sudden you've got 20K
verified this is patterned in one day
yeah like what was the feeling like was
it like calm my news was going to happen
or was it a bit like [__] hell like
no I mean I had I had um so I had chunks
a chunks Sharky AJ all of those people
they were all around me and they were
like yo this is gonna This is Gonna Fly
but they didn't they didn't they didn't
know how it didn't anticipate 20K in two
days yeah yeah they thought yeah you're
gonna get you're probably gonna get a
few K like
um in the first day or something I was
like okay cool fair enough well
obviously see in 20 seconds like
I had one video and it was introduction
it's a two minute video essentially hey
guys I'm starting a channel that uh
expect videos on my channel soon
highlights
no no because I wasn't I didn't think I
was lying at the time but at least after
since 2017 till now I think I've got
like less than 40 videos on my channel
it's horrible
[Laughter]
at this point that you're right now like
where
what's the plan the plan oh you know I'm
rich now so it's just um
I know what rich is and I'm not there
yeah but I'm better yeah let's go let's
go
um so what was the question sir
um oh yeah what's the plans oh it's a
plan now plan yeah um
obviously now the planet I've said this
so many times but I wanna I wanna get
back on my channel okay because I'd like
to believe regardless of all the other
things I've done my channel is what got
me here yeah yeah
what got me here so I kind of just been
content with what I've been doing well
outside of my channel as opposed to just
being focused on what to do with my own
channel so it's just yeah I think I
think right now the plan is I'm still
going to keep doing what I'm doing but I
need to focus on my channel more and
upload cool because
um my supporters deserve it they do bro
they do that's a
fair play fair play fair play not enough
people say that fair play uh yeah yeah
all the time
without these look that watch it yeah
I'll be fine I'm not here yeah
I love it and some of them you know how
much you know love is um
the supporters that come up to me in
real life and they'll say yo but I've
been watching since I was 14 and he
looks older than me
since I was 14. and then they'll show me
a selfie we took in in like literally
end of 2016 and I had like glasses and I
was and I'm like yeah that's me yeah and
it's him as a you and he's taking a
picture and then he'll take a picture of
me again years later that same guy and
then I'm just like and at least that one
person will just like oh my God I love
it just makes me think about all my
sport yeah I was like I love these guys
like these look they're honestly the
best because 90 I'd say 97 of the people
that approached me always positive yeah
I can only imagine that yeah it's always
positive you guys you guys um I give
props to you man we did a [__]
we used to do this thing on the channel
where we do like uh
create uh [__] appreciation
appreciation he was in there one day
yeah yeah yeah he was in there one day
yeah yeah yeah
um and then yeah we talk about like just
human in general uh like you trunks best
spot everyone just like
very nice positivity like a lot of
people like a lot of people become
Successful by like critiquing others or
pranking others or hurt in others and
all this other [__] and like you guys
consistently managed to do like very
very positive things keep it funny and
just keep coming up and it's it's very
very very very nice and it's very very
refreshing so I can see why you like I
can see why you've got someone coming up
to you that's like [__] eight years
deep yeah and he's rolling through and
it's I think it's [__] decent I
forgot that he was in there one day
um also one question what's it like
what's it like actually like before even
before you started your channel and then
once your Channel's young and you've
been featured in all these videos what's
it like growing up in a YouTuber
community so like for me and Frieda for
example
we go to all these places now we don't
know anyone everyone seems to know who
we are we don't know anyone let's relax
every like literally every single person
there knows exactly who we are yeah
but yeah it's weird like it's a very
very very like uncomfortable feeling
yeah uh it's very very uncomfortable and
it's like very very very new for us like
pretty much like in the last year yeah
yeah
um
and it almost feels like we're every
time we walk through the door I don't
know if it feels the same but every time
I walk through your door it feels like
everyone's in on some secret thing that
we don't know about do you know what I
mean like it seems like everyone knows
everyone who knows everyone and they're
all like oh they were already in the
room yeah and then we walk in the room
we're just like
mm-hmm what's going on what's it like
like literally being surrounded by these
people from like from years and years
and years and years and consistently
being surrounded by creators
consistently in this like YouTube like
consistently always being stopped by
people for like years and years and
years what's that been like for you so
um
slight error there's because the people
I've been consistently around or this
are like the beta Squad it's very
limited people that's consistently been
around I'm saying growing up before what
um when I was getting into the community
and stuff I I had my social anxiety was
up to it honestly like I wouldn't go
anywhere like literally so I'd be just
and indoors you if I if I was to go out
just be like with people I know yeah but
I wouldn't go to events I would never
the event that you that I met you at was
the first event that I've been to in
three years
literally and I came by myself yeah they
made everyone go by themselves oh bro
that was the worst event I'm so happy
this I'm so happy I've got this Giza bro
they wouldn't let anyone bring someone
every single person we met that event
was on by myself I was like [__] all of
that bro but in terms of the other
creators and how they and how they meet
it's either they message each other and
they say yo let's work on this so
there's already they're already familiar
with each other or they meet the same
way me and you guys met like at an event
oh I watch you oh I know you too I love
here take my details and then we talk
and then now we're here that's exactly
how it happens I think with a lot of
these people a lot a lot of a lot of
what goes on in the community is just
networking I think a lot of it's just
talking to people talk to people you
find funny yeah and just be like yo I
think me and you were Joe together
um how can we make it work or if it's
not that maybe you just like the Sun but
like the person's Vibe and we're just
happy to be friends even though we do
the same thing so it's I think it's just
that I think it's just obviously now I
think it's a lot of with what I'm trying
to do is
go to like a lot of these events it's
like and meet other creators because
fair enough I might know who they are
who they are by face or they might know
who I am but I've never met you I've
never had a conversation with you yeah
so I don't know what you're like in
person so I think with me it's right now
I'm not experienced in terms of
networking because I've really just
stayed within the the circle that I've
started with yeah yeah I'm saying you
know you know the names so it's just
I've kind of stayed consistent with them
and that's kind of how I made my name
even though like the little you might
see me here with different people but um
that was that's just that I just kind of
see that I just kind of saw that as work
I didn't really see that as networking
so now it's just I think in terms of
that's what I'm trying to change about
myself because now I'm a bit more grown
I care a bit less about about certain
things so I'm much more open to going to
places and just and yeah and just sort
of you know picking other people's
brains and hopefully working with more
people and being more having more
friends within the industry okay hang
yeah I want to have more friends
please yeah
can we just do like 10 minutes of just
like anime chat without anyone in here
who loves anime cool cool cool cool
right when did you start watching anime
when did I start watching them yeah I
started watching anime when I was
um about 12 years old I would struggle
was it that's what introduced me I
remember sitting down my mom made me
food I was sat in front of the TV and I
was just like when I saw Super Saiyan I
actually just dropped my fork and I was
just like this my food is getting cold I
remember that's my first time watching
like the like anime so I started off
with Dragon Ball Z but the first proper
anime I'm talking like Dragon Ball Z
account as an anime yeah but it's like
that's child yeah so I'd say the first
anime I watched I was in year eight it
was Naruto yeah Naruto was the first
anime I watched okay guys so I watched
it I was like I love this carried on
watching until it finished
then I started watching One Piece Naruto
then one piece straight after and then
one piece at the time only had like 300
episodes 300 episodes so
um yeah finish that and then I just kept
I think well I'm up to date on at least
20 to 25 enemies now wow yeah because
I've loved the idea of it anime is the
best thing ever yeah so I want to say
what's your top three I was about to ask
you yeah you're right you're top three
yeah I want to know yours all right
top three is hard yeah I know top three
I need I need like I need wine I don't
drink people yeah
top three I've seen stuff yes same
I would say
I'm saying in terms of storyline the
fights the the characters [__]
you know what's annoying I used to have
I deleted the notes I used to have a
list of every anime I've ever watched
there was like 78 on there yeah
um and I accidentally deleted it I'm Vex
um damn my top three just saying I'm
probably gonna change it I will always
change mine I know I'm gonna get hate
for saying this because it's so like
young demon Slayers in there
no Demon Slayer is a very good anime but
top three
okay I [__] love it I'm not angry at
that I'm not angry at that I might
change I might take it out but I love I
[__] love it yeah
um so that's number three yeah probably
number three
I feel like Naruto has to be in there
okay even though it might not be the
best but it just has like that place in
my heart yeah yeah that's like my
childhood yeah
um maybe Hunter or Naruto is like maybe
tied yeah
um and then
maybe like death note that's not what's
called I love Death Note yeah yeah maybe
oh by the time you manage probably be a
brand new three three but yeah I every
time I get asked what's my one of my
favorite enemies I always say Hunter x
Hunter so that's gonna be a top three
that has to be important Hunter x Hunter
actually by law of facts I've seen that
maybe three times now I've seen it three
times
um damn
um what else took my soul pause
um
direct competitors and they're both
heavy as [__] yeah but it doesn't really
count as an anime but I [__] love
Avatar I knew you're gonna say I looked
at it
there's an anime yeah I guess yeah the
original one
oh wow I've seen that five or six times
fair
all right George ferrito
fairy tale I watched like you know what
yeah that's what myself
in case you forgot one I watched like 30
episodes of it and I remember at a time
I'm hoping they wouldn't do like a new
chapter but like the fight was the same
thing every episode for like
10 15 20 episodes it was just like
spot a villain
two of the like Mages will get marked
same structure whatever Natsu will come
in get smacked then it'd go op and then
smack the person that happened time and
time and time and time again no one got
new powers no one developed no one did
anything it was just the same routine
okay and I was like I'm not watching
this anymore okay I heard it's hard
I'm still trying to think all right I'm
just gonna throw I have to throw in
um I have to throw demons layer I just
have the movies yeah but Demon Slayer
the movie that came out with Demon
Slayer was the best anime movie I
watched they were trained one oh yeah
zero movies better than Divas
Jujitsu is amazing
I just didn't like the animation of The
Ting in the train it was different
animation I didn't like it bro okay I'm
just being honest I didn't like the
animation oh the actual demon trained oh
yeah yeah animation it was different I
was like it just doesn't blend well for
me that's the reason why I didn't like
it as much everything else
it doesn't matter
AKA Zero movie that was impossibly hard
yeah
I've never seen the movie I've heard the
movie's good yeah I've never watched the
anime completely oh really it's 400
episodes yeah it's cool I watched like
100 episodes of that um okay my last one
would be damn I'm gonna go wrong oh
[__] no you can say I'm gonna go
Rogue and you man can't send me for this
I'm telling you about how it made me
feel oh [__] yeah I was when I say I was
locked in go on bro it's not number one
but I'm just gonna throw that Haiku
haiku's hard to be fair Haiku hike is
very very hot the volleyball
I'll put my life on it
locks me in volleyball bro bro unless
the ball turns on fire and someone says
bro
haikus
character development heavy okay but I
wouldn't I wouldn't say it's the number
one anime I've watched but in terms of
person like personally I'm like yeah
this is a heavy anime that's fair yeah
they're completely Fair all right go top
three for you oh it's my girl uh um okay
easy fast for me fast has to be one one
piece it's it's rude for me to say
anything else okay say it has to be
number one
bro no because you know it is I've the
when I started watching it in year 9 up
until now no show forget anime no show
has had me hooked the same way the show
has um you know it's the anime right now
there's a 1073 episodes thousand to 73
yeah I'm a year ahead because I'm up to
date on the mango I'm literally a whole
year I know what's gonna happen every
week for a year with the mango
and by the way we still don't know [__]
no stood on this [__] but I'm still I'm
still at this like it's not it hasn't
reached a point where like think about
it think about a lot of the shows you uh
watch like Prison Break for example
Prison Break season wanted to see season
two very good after that it's like it
falls out yeah how many times you're
gonna break out of a prison yeah money
Heist like okay you broke into a bank
sick you can just keep breaking into
brexit yeah like a lot of those shows
have that repetitiveness where they just
don't let things die but this is pretty
much the same thing but it's just like
you have to every person I've talked
about one piece has never told me I'm a
little list of [__] please just take
your time I've tried and I'll chat to
you in 10 years when you're finished
this movie thing I need to figure out
what movies to watch I'll send you a
tick I will send you a tick tock this
guy gave a full breakdown I was like
watch this movie watch this movie watch
this movie it's like five movies and it
will get you up to like episode a
thousand that's what that's why
yeah where it gets juicy or maybe a nice
thousand maybe like 600 or 700 that's
what I need that's completely fine yeah
there's still more questions just call
me back I watched like 150. I remember
when I was younger someone was like it's
like 100 episodes and you have to firm
it and then and you literally bro it's
not not firm as in this as [__] as a lot
of just what please just get into it I
just I learned the story try to get
hooked I watched and they were like oh
once you get into like the crocodile Arc
oh Lord yeah it's long yeah bro it's
long from there oh [__] I I watched on
the Pirates thing yeah where's my keys
hold on
or something
but I've got a gold Straw Hat oh yeah
all right all right calm and I'm keep
them getting buried with this
oh okay
yeah I watched like 150 episodes yeah
and then it was like trust me bro once
you get to this crocodile Arc and he
scratch crocodile it gets hard and I was
like gang yeah and I did watch him scrap
him and it was hard and I was like cool
and then that Arc ended and they started
the brand new arc and it was dead again
yeah I believe it for like another 50
and I was like I can't do this anymore
like I've waited so long I can't do it
anymore so I just locked it yeah I'm
gonna watch the movies no watch the
movies anything you need to and watch
the war there's a war that happens you
need to watch the wall there's just so
much stuff that happened anyways I could
be here if I always talk about it okay
so one piece number one it's number one
by Fox in the ceiling okay
um second would be Hunter
to someone that doesn't watch anime at
all if I was to give someone advice on
the first anime to watch Hunter Hunter's
very very strong shout out because
literally 150 episodes get out the way
you will love anime yeah because it's
fantastic and it's amazing you'll love
it from the beginning to the end oh
pacing sick as well in it perfectly
paced they got their like um Hunter
cards in like 10 to 20 episodes and
you're like gang okay cool because I
thought that was going to be the whole
thing for time I [__] love that show
yeah and then third would be bleach
peaches go leech very very good this new
arc is one I will give bleach their
props for wait in [__] 10 years and
then bring out a new Arc of that
newark's probably the hardest art
because of all of it yeah so yeah yeah
right into bleach I love it um but yeah
what did you say was your top free I
said Hunter Hunter what haiku's number
one for you no I see I didn't do it in
three two one I'm just saying okay
you're just saying what Hunter Haiku um
I might change I'm gonna take Haiku off
maybe drop that in the top five yeah and
replace for Attack on Titan Attack on
Titan
oh yeah
makes it to my top five I think but
maybe even top ten they gave me a whole
season of [__] oh yeah yeah season
four political thing they were doing
that whatever yeah that dropped way down
for me but yes it's oh wow apart from
that the storyline first episode Bonkers
damn the attack on Titan is a great shot
I can't believe I forgot okay anyway
back to the origin story question for
you where did the name darkest man come
from
um okay story's not too long with this
actually Okay cool so chunks and Sharky
wanted to know transported to record um
a carpool karaoke I wasn't in the video
I was supposed to be in the video you
weren't supposed to be no I wasn't
supposed to be in the video so chunks
literally was right outside the house so
chunks in the car Sharky was in the car
and then they were just filming they
were filming singing I walked past the
car to go to the shop
so I'm wearing a black hoodie black
bomber jacket black shorts black sliders
so I'm blacked out at this point yeah so
I'll go to the shop and I come out I got
my grandma all my snacks whatever so I'm
walking past the car so as I'm walking
past the car trunks puts down the window
and he's like yo come on come jump in
the video real quick and I was like I
was like bro look at me I was like look
at me I was like I just want to go
inside eat my snacks and I'll just
jumping jumping jumping I was at all
right course anymore so I jumped in the
video and I was like okay cool I need a
I need an intro I want to scream I I
just want to scream and say yo guys but
I was like I need to give myself a name
and then I looked I was wearing all
black I was the darkest guy in that car
so yeah so I was just like it's the
darkest man in the world I literally
just came up oh okay
just never left That's Heavy yeah
literally Origins I came up with the
name in two seconds that's sick yeah
just me getting in the car is that what
I say what I say it's the darkest one
yeah oh fair enough that's two wholesome
I love stairs like that yeah I [__]
hate I hate that our origin story is so
dead what do we make with the name of
the oh no no no
say it's alive
but telling people my name is a bit of a
especially people that don't know who I
am what's your name
at that point I just have to give my
coffee yeah I'm not gonna lie you
couldn't approach me and me asking your
name and you say dog yeah what are you
saying my brother because I've been
thinking I would I I would want to laugh
but I don't know if it's a laugh or not
I'd want to I'd question myself in like
what did I ask you yes
I mean you know when you start looking
through something because in your head
you're doing backflips you think what
did I ask what did I asked am I sure
yeah no your name your name is your name
and I'll be thinking like is is there
accent situations
stop please
oh yeah
um oh wow that's a joke all right cool
ram should we jump into the trash news
yeah boy right cool so yeah we're gonna
look at tracks
trash news now and I've seen I've seen
the title of this the other day you've
seen Blindside
all right cool so before we get into
this let me explain what the Blind Side
is if anyone for whatever reason hasn't
seen The Blind Side first of all shame
on you second of all it's a true story
about this guy I call I want to top my
head I want to say Michael Oher yep dang
right so this Giza yeah Michael Oher was
some
basically like teenage broke boy
um whose mum was like a crackhead and
all this kind of stuff it was basically
on the streets but he was Wham and
strong as [__] and athletic as [__] so
he got spotted by this white lady uh
Leanne Tui I think it's how you
pronounce it yep um
you got sued spotted
yeah she was at the school she was just
at school and him and his boy were just
playing basketball in the school sorry
okay so
got spotted
um by the coach as well right yeah I
think coach clocked him first he started
playing football for this school and
they put him on a scholarship and all
sorts in it started playing football for
this high school he was unbelievable but
then this lady Leanne Tui realized that
he was just like sleeping on the streets
so he was just like leaving the high
school games and just sleeping on the
street or sleeping in the school so she
took him in fed him clothed him and he
basically just like lived with this
white family for years and then um but
they were big big big big big big into
football yeah like they were super rich
family who just like funded college
football teams
um and there was a lot of drama at the
time as whether they had
ulterior motives about what they were
doing with this guy and whether it was
like because they adopted him right I
can't remember I think they tried to
adopt him
um they didn't adopt him
um that's part of this part of this this
thing's part of the issue yeah they
don't know
it was either he thought they adopted
him but it was a conservatorship
ah like a Britney Spears take a Britney
Spears
this is what the juice is the issue if
he was adopted and he understood he was
adopted at the time then right now he
wouldn't be having this issues that he's
having being 37 and retired from the NFL
um and needing any money he wouldn't
need any money because being adopted he
would have sorry run it back a little
bit needing any money from the the
documentary that came out
money was made from the family the tuis
if he was adopted it would have been
fight he would have been included in all
of that he's claiming now that because
it is a conservative ship and he didn't
understand at the time of his young age
he was a conservatorship
he didn't get any peace from that from
The Blind Side from The Blind Side he
said he didn't get no peace from that
oh I swear that's the issue but the
other narrative is that how did he not
understand that it was a concern or he
did understand it was a conservative
ship people are saying and that it's
just Peak timing that now he's 37
retired from the NFL and he's just and
now he's now he's saying coincidentally
understanding that it was a conservative
and he's not getting anything I see
because now he's got no [__] income
I see and he's already written a book in
2011. oh they're saying that back then
seemed to be up or everything's in the
understood things back in 2011. damn now
okay so so back so this family that
adopted him there was a documentary that
came out the whole thing the family got
money but he didn't yeah so the movie
The Blind Side came out yes big boy
movies in it yeah yeah
um that came out in whatever year it
came out in 2009 2009 yep I swear
years and years ago [__] yeah 2009 are
you serious I generally thought it came
out over there and I just didn't want it
bro wow poverty by a wealthy white
family was
old
2009 are you winding me up The Blind
Side came on 2009
yeah Jesus all right fair play yeah
anyway so the movie come out he didn't
get any money for this movie this what I
understand from reading this year okay
and now he's trying to sue them in 2023
because he's broke he's broke clearly
and he didn't get any money from the
blind that alone is mad to me that he
got zero money from The Blind Side and
this is because the I'm assuming the
family
agreed for the Blind Side to come out
he must have agreed
well that's the thing with the
conservatorship they didn't need for him
to agree so I'm assuming in 2009 he was
still under the conservatorship yeah I
see now
oh [__] oh so as a conservatorship you
basically own them in it yeah so they're
not part of the family yeah it's not
adoption no it's typical for when
someone say old age you make the
decisions for them that someone is
unwell common decisions for themselves
can we just hold the phone for a second
what's conservatorship fam right cool so
I was I'm not gonna lie to you man I was
trying to figure out as I was talking
the only time I've ever heard of
conservatorship Paul is the Britney
Spears thing so what are you gonna say
politics I'll let you oh you talk about
conservatives
oh right
yeah we're gonna have to read right we
have to re-up yeah yeah we're gonna
really have to go key stage three on
this
um
right a conservative ship from what I
know correct me where I'm wrong
is where basically yeah like what um
what REM said when someone can't look
after themselves or can't be trusted to
look after themselves your point per
someone to manage all of their yeah
financial and personal affairs so this
is yeah this applies like yo you live
with me I look after you but I ended up
to do it yeah so I'm Your Guardian so
this basically says if you're underage
it means you're the guardian or if
you're incapacitated you're basically
like there you run they run your money
so yeah if you just like got hit by a
bus God forbid stop and then like you
can still like actively move talk all
this kind of stuff but you might need
someone to manage your Affairs yeah
that's a conservative ship but you have
to give them like legal rights to all
your [__] so when you're under the
conservatorship technically they can do
what they want with your [__] so they
can they can sign contracts for you they
can write their name as like the
beneficiary from all your contracts and
you've basically
written your life away to this person
isn't it and that's what the big Britney
Spears drama was about yeah is that they
put her under a conservative ship
because they said huh well she was a kid
that wasn't the one she was kidding this
is when she was grown adults um and she
started going a bit nuts yeah yeah her
dad
yeah no I'm just saying I don't know how
nuts sounds
um it's your life it's your life bro
it's your life if you think
nothing's an appropriate term then okay
[Applause]
yeah when Britney was moving sauce her
dad was basically like cool
conservatorship she's not mentally
capable of like making decisions making
decision for herself so then they put
her on the conservation ship but while
she was under that conservative ship
they made her work they gave it like a
residency in Vegas so all this time
they're like oh she's incapable she's
incapable but they were just like Corky
enough for money and the dad was taking
like a humongous portion of the money
um himself so that's a dodgy thing about
conservatorship so basically I'm
assuming in this Michael Oher case he's
saying I thought I was adopted I thought
I was part of this family I didn't
understand that I was actually part of a
conservatorship and these men were
actually
robbing me blind they owned me yeah um
so they were actually in charge I think
I read a little piece about that all of
his um whilst he was still underage
herself all of his contracts they owned
as well in it I believe so yeah I'll
have a little read through something
okay
but yeah basically now it's only coming
out here and I can't it just makes it
sound like a Hustle
like that literally because no way so he
got at 37 when he retired and he's got
nothing left
Oscar win a film that earned more than
300 million and he got an okay
does it say how much the two he found he
got for for the Blind Side
um well this Oscar winning film that
earned more than 300 mil bro I'm saying
I don't think there you go while ower
got nothing for a story that would not
have existed without him uh in the years
since the chewies have continued calling
the 37 year olds please carry on reading
um and use their assertion to promote
their Foundation as well as Lee Leanne
tui's work and the author and
motivational speaker so wait so now I've
taken your money but your name is still
supporting my work as an author and a
motivational speaker so she's still
living off that so so wait I'm sorry lay
anturi's work as an author and a
motivational speaker yeah yeah
yeah 100 yeah
yeah he owned restaurants but she didn't
have a job right no so purely based on
this she's now a motivational speaker
yes well she's only a motivational
speaker because of this because of
Donnie yeah yeah yeah yeah so from all
of this Michael's never earned any money
he's only on NFL money yeah he would
have got his nflp yeah but that's it
though what people that's it what people
are questioning though is watch
what she did for him she took him off
the streets
that's why I said that's why I said I
could play Devil's advocacy please she
played mother role for him when he when
when he was down bad uh before she oh
she picked him up so that's where people
are saying Okay so
now you're just being ungrateful to
Michael
um and you're just gonna completely
ignore that and now you're down bad
financially only now has it become a
problem so it's just the timing of
everything involved I agree with that
yeah but you know what yeah I'm I'm
again Playing devil's Africa
[__] as far as I'm concerned [__] your
time in if I'm making 20 30 40 mil a
year in the NFL and now I'm not making
nothing because if I'm making 40 ml a
year in the NFL yeah
granted yeah I'm not making money Here
There and Everywhere because it may be a
situation where I was like
let's say we're making I don't know a
[__] Mill a year on YouTube whatever
and then someone's posting our [__] on
Snapchat and they're making
half a million year I might look here
and be like that's kind of [__] up but
like I'm just getting on with my days
like it's whatever or maybe they're
making 100K and it's like it's it's
whatever
but now
YouTube's died we're done we're not
making any money and I'm still looking
over here granted
time in or no time in the fact is the
fact is the fact maybe I didn't need the
money then but I need the money now and
yeah it's still my [__] [__] yeah so
just because I'm coming after you now
that I'm broke doesn't mean that my
claim is not substantial
yeah
I'm not coming back like I'm not asking
for help I'm asking for myself yeah I'm
asking for my stuff Bro [__] okay yeah I
just let you hold it because I didn't
need it now I need it run me my [__]
yeah Fair
um but you know I get both sides so
people are trying to say yo without the
mother you still would have been
sleeping on the street yeah so
oxy but you know is there's ways of
doing things like just because you don't
have any other options doesn't mean I'm
going to take you in and act like you're
a robot and just take everything you
produce
yeah so now obviously and regardless of
that it's after he's 37 now he's got
nothing you have to merge has to look at
him and be like yo I have to drop you
something like I have to I have to give
you something I would agree bro
especially if she's still making an
income from this of course and it's his
face bro there's no story without him
yeah yeah yeah so granted yeah he would
be nothing without her but as far as
this is concerned they need to travel
that's right as far as her career is
concerned she'll be nothing without him
facts um so yeah we've got a
and plus you start off Rich do you know
anybody if she was BR if she was a broke
human being by herself with yeah I mean
just like a broke down car small house
and she took him in and then they became
millionaires she'd have more of a say as
to say okay cool maybe maybe I can
justify you a little bit more but you're
already rich yeah oh yeah you're already
affordable yeah like as well you made me
Rich and then storm and then yeah you
know what makes it like it says if
that's actually the case she's evil I
don't agree with that there's ways of
there's ways of doing things yeah
very interesting story it is that's
amazing I'm intrigued to see how this
pops it goes further than actually oh go
on go go go so a little spin-off from
this obviously the the um the Blind Side
itself Sandra Bullock as we know played
uh Leanne Tui great woman cancel great
woman yeah Council culture
once Sandra Bullock's Oscar returned for
this movie that she that she okay now
we're just losing ourselves
come on I've never had a valid reason
for anything oh yeah actually they're
completely out like that's what I'm
saying that's how far people are taking
and saying the people who are trying to
like back up Michael's uh case of course
yeah yeah they're going that far if I
was Sandra I'll tell this man to come
and get it yeah if you're bad you know
where I live I acted my tits I would
have pissed on it and sent it to all of
them I don't know literally oh oh yeah
if I was Sandra I say you might go shut
up this has nothing to do the fact that
they say a return to Mission did a great
job like I convinced you yeah
all right okay this is the juice okay
cool I'm gonna follow this I'm actually
gonna follow this story because I'm
intrigued to see if he gets anything
from it he should hopefully he should he
deserves it but also I think what I kept
on thinking about is you play for NFL
for how many years does it say
um regardless of how many years he
played for he played for more than one
yeah stack come on like see what I'm
saying like and if our players get paid
they do they get paid yearly sums same
with NBA they get paid their yearly sum
so how do you not have by the way did
this movie come out while he was playing
I think so I think so because at the end
of the movie there's like clips of him
playing like on the field and stuff yeah
yeah he probably had this as a backup
plan but he just didn't know he wasn't
getting anything maybe maybe
Ravens they won this he was a member of
a Super Bowl winning team yeah he wanted
to we want to bring
to say his estimated earnings on there
so he played for eight years
he played for six years
what does it say so he plays Five
Seasons Five Seasons and then one season
made one season in Tennessee and his
final final two stories are you right
you're right you're right you're right
eight yeah okay eight years in the NFL
is a stack that's what I'm saying um
yeah how much how much earnings did he
get his contract his contract for five
years was 13 mil
chat see what I'm saying like he you
could have say something that's a
ridiculous amount of money total
guarantees just under seven mil
all right bro I can understand lifestyle
I can understand helping with your
family and friends but if you're not
like okay after after tax and everything
he's probably got like a Milton yeah so
like
is let's say you made Seven mil what a
mill no I'm saying a year though in it
to be fair after tax seven like even if
you got that seven not all not all of
that okay okay you'll eat half of that
is going to tax
10 as that is going to his agent ten
percent of that going to his manager
yeah
um he's probably coming out with like
two three mil
fur and blood signs made 300 mil fair I
would have been angry yeah okay
I must actually know that much I'm
scared now what yeah yeah
like three mil mm-hmm
well surely they would have
that's just NFL earnings though he would
have like endorsed yeah
because that's where the more money is I
don't know though you know how many
people are on an NFL team Fair he might
not have a single endorsement that's
like 30 at a man
yeah and if there's one sport I never
understood I don't know the rules at all
I just know you throw an egg catch it
yeah yeah when they when they go like
offense on defense on that I'm like bro
but yeah this is intriguing yeah very
very intriguing juicy one bro that's
probably the best fashion news you
bought say less fair play very intrigued
all right what we got next
all right cool so you'd like to run bar
sometimes in it yeah sometimes yeah yeah
quick but so yeah we've got a game that
we've been playing the last few weeks
called Rhyme Time
um and all we're gonna do is just run a
couple lyrics so it could be a case of
like I would say something like I'm
Chris Brown and then if you had would
say
um I'm feeling quite depressed I'm Chris
down and then REM could say yeah like I
got a big red nose on Chris clown okay
so we're gonna run it like that okay all
right fair enough fortunately for you
our editor Ellis is not here he would
spin your jaw lyrics I'm confident that
Ellis will spin your jaw lyrically so
you might stand a chance today still all
right bet I'll do my best which way are
we going we're gonna go we'll give him a
chance so we'll go
in fact it's probably it's probably true
both ways bro
[Laughter]
I get excited until
um anyway
um right cool right cool cool Google
um what I'll do then since we're doing
it that way I will say it I'll say the
the name and then I'll do my first one
okay say less I'm Spiderman they call me
Uchiha
I'm from the spider Clan
I'm sitting next to darkest but I'm
inspired a tan
I might see a support I might see a
spider fan
it's getting a bit sweet in here I'm
gonna spread that Spider Jam
I've had a long life
this is my spider span
oh
call me Avengers because I'm with my
spider gang okay
[Music]
If This Was Kung Fu I'll be with spider
Lee and spider Chan
it's too quick that's hella quick oh my
God
damn all right
I need to holler the elders or someone
needs to call my spider Nan
[Music]
um
I stayed cooking
I'm using my spider pan damn I was going
to say something with band but I can't
think of something but yeah I'm out I'm
out I'm out bro I was racing I'm just
trying to go gym and just trying to get
spiderweb oh this son of a [__] it's
actually too easy too easy for him
I'm about to get carried to push me my
spider pram oh say that's well played
all you Mana fake this is whole a spider
sham
I know you can't do it but spider can
stop no
Jesus
oh maybe you were smoking yeah maybe you
would swing it [__] you now
look Ella's pissed me off
[Laughter]
I wasn't expecting that Rob okay okay
yeah okay okay
yeah double oh say yes what's the next
one all right cool Google next one next
one yeah
right cool cool cool
right I'm a little Oozy feeling quite
feminine call me Little Susie
I'm a little bit tipsy call me a little
boozy
you're a little bit tipsy but I'm
getting a little woozy
that's a blind
these lyrics are fire I'm going to think
about this get choosy oh
I can't stop sleeping around they call
me a little floozy
people think they're bad I can't
remember their name like Lil who's he
is
I'm not gonna lie you might have won I
might be a little loser quick with it
you have to add you have to actually
make up words yeah literally
get out charged I'm out I'm out I'm out
um
rubbing shoulder to shoulder I'm getting
a little schmoozy
damn I can't think of anything else
I can't I'm done I'm done I thought you
were playing
yeah I mean okay so if I give you a
little one can you give me a little
Tuesday
it's crazy
[Laughter]
this guy's boring a shot at me I'm
feeling a little snoozy oh that's why
I'm wearing sliders I don't like little
shoes
[Applause]
you have bro
okay okay okay I'm nervous go this way
I'm nervous I can't go this way again
all right last one REM you're next [__]
okay [__] man
um all right these are going to be
similar Rhymes I think actually Tom
Cruise
oh yeah we're gonna run it back again
all right Tom Cruise
can't keep the bottle out of my hand
call me Tom booze you men are making me
fall asleep
Thompson news cool we're cooking
well I'm gonna make I'm gonna wake you
up might give you a Tom bruise oh my God
some people call ah some people call me
Tom Wynn you must be Tom loose I was
gonna say that
they call me undecisive indecisive I
can't Tom choose
drop a hint here or there give me that
Tom Clues oh my God that was good
I like to chill in Tom Lyons and Tom
Cruise
excuse Tom lines
yeah I'm with you I'm with you
this Mission seems impossible standing
in a crowd full of Tom Boos poor
oh okay okay okay I'm just throwing
stuff out
all you men are so happy I got the Tom
Blues
I'll catch this dub as I want a ton lose
we said lose yeah sorry bro damn it I'm
sorry bro ggs
I might have to say Tom pause because
I'm gonna ask for some Tom nudes
oh my God I can't think of any more
and this is not right okay okay okay
I'm not a rhyme I'm done okay
he can't get the dub again someone
called the BBC because I'm Tom news
you're staring into space like you're
staring into Tom's boobs
I'm running the same mind back getting
shoulder to shoulder call me Tom
schmooze I'm running the same mind back
to save time bro
all right cool
um
the first time he stole fam I know
uh regardless if I lose I'm gonna stay
on my Tom twos
um
I'm running the same line back keep on
your sliders bro I got my Tom shoes
I know Tom drinks but I don't know if
Tom Foods
enough
I feel I'm sorry I've got nothing left
I've got nothing left yeah babe oh wow
[Applause]
right so we've come to the well played
by the way
um so we've come to the climax of the
show and this every time you have a
guest on this part of the show we ask
the fandom to send us in questions that
they would like to ask you but we twist
it and we give you the iPad you read the
other questions you answer the questions
yourself no problem so this is from the
fandom from the cult babies all right
this is what they want to know about
darkest okay
what was the moment you knew you made it
cheers I don't want to sound like
arrogant here if that's the word but no
I said it's too much to remember so much
moment no that's good
I'll just like yeah like there's so much
moments that make me feel like oh my God
I made it um what sticks out the most
though what would you say I say when I
say when a little girl cried with
swimming oh all right bro I take tip
both tears I I didn't I'm not a hard guy
to find yeah yeah so it's just like the
fact that you like she saw me she was
like
okay
Legend I was like oh second one um How
much would it take for you and Trunks to
scrap oh
that's a good question
um
I'll be real it's I wouldn't scrap him
I wouldn't scrap him I can't it's it's
just it's even weird to even think about
because you know as me and him I like to
believe we don't even have arguments bro
okay that's good really we really don't
argue because I'd like to believe
obviously we did when we were younger
what I'm saying as a recently I can't
remember last time I made him really
argue like we um we have a we have a
very good understanding like we know
what I know what he likes I know what
annoys him I know what he doesn't like
he knows yeah yeah they got it from
Facebook you [__]
that's a throwback oh like an actual
[__] oh my God mad uh but yeah it
would actually it would take it would
take the worst for me to scratch because
even if he was telling it will take you
from black to hit me but he would never
hit me and I'll never hit him so it
would have to be like something he'd
have to say something absolutely mad
insane yeah crazy yeah like I don't want
to give him yeah
I mean all right cool I would have scrap
him under any circumstances but okay
yeah so third what took you so long to
get into content creating
um
I didn't have a passion for it because
it wasn't my idea to start YouTube it
was chunk's idea trunks trunks was the
one I was like yo YouTube I want to
start bought a camera I bought this
stuff and I just featured and then from
there people just wanted me to start my
own content so it wasn't really an
ambition of mine to start my own content
but after a while after doing it for a
while uh I kind of I kind of got a kick
out of making people's laugh people
laugh and I just learned to love it
I generally I love the pressure I love
the passion when I make someone laugh I
like it just makes me happy
yeah so it's just yeah I've always had
that and then that's but in terms of
what took me so long it's just you know
it wasn't my idea it was I didn't have a
passion for it I just kind of had to
work into it but yeah okay cool next one
what's something big you did that you
regret
oh
one that's actually okay cool I I'll
tell you this it was my first shoot with
first one my first trip was on they made
basically my top three fears first is
cows then it's dogs in it oh okay cows
cows they're the it's a couch with legs
like how like this no it's not but it's
not you can't you have to like cows you
know hold on you know they killed 22
people a year I swear Google it
how much people yeah
they killed 22 people here they don't
ramp Rod to be fair I told the stories
when I was leaving one of our boys yards
he lives on a farm oh my God 22 people
here wow
Raw
normal people because okay that's
excessive the last bit yeah we didn't
ask that bit all right
um so your life could be on the line
just getting milk you know what I'm
saying milk Fair facts so
um what's something big that you did
that you regret
yeah so they made me get they made me
wear those big suits that you get that
you wear when a dog Chaser oh my God
yeah yeah so yeah usually I think oh my
God like oh I did that I hated the whole
I hate everything like this you can see
me that was my first actual like gig in
front of like cameras and stuff oh I did
not say a single word for four videos we
recorded four videos that day I didn't
say I I think I said one word just the
intro hey guys welcome back to
throughout the whole time I was just
quiet because I hate dogs I do not like
them I don't like dogs so
um yeah hopefully yeah that I told this
day I still regret it right damn that is
good I guess I guess it was needed
anyways
um second one who's the most annoying
beta Squad member no one's really
annoying but um
ethnicities would you date
um I'll be honest with you there's not a
top three that's not a top five not top
ten it's just I don't really I don't
look at ethnicity as like a big thing
okay it's just more it's just on the
individual really so I don't really look
like I'm not saying oh you're Jamaican
you must act like this oh you're Chinese
you must act like this you're Indian you
must act like this it's just it just
depends on the individual you're dealing
with I don't really think ethnicity
maybe ethnicity has a lot to do with how
you were brought up 100 but in terms of
how you view the world your likes and
dislikes that's just more you so yeah
yeah yeah so I I don't really have a
preference on ethnicities to be fair
um have you ever experienced
islamophobia from being in the Limelight
islamophobia so people
violate me for being Muslim yes
[Music]
I'm not really one with the words yeah
yeah so
um
people violating me for being Muslim
sorry that is literally what it is so
why do you just say that
all right cool from being in the
Limelight um
yeah I mean you get stupid comments like
um obviously I don't know if I can say
this well these are actual things I've
read but they've made me laugh because
yeah because you know anyone that
violates me for being Muslim or like
violates my uh my religion anyway I just
I find it more funny because like where
where's this anger coming from yeah see
what I'm saying to you like because I
just see you as stupid because like you
can't be angry at crazy person it's like
being you can't hate an idiot yeah you
know what I'm saying to you so that's
like that's it doesn't really affect me
but have I experienced it yeah sure
um fair enough never in real life
they're always in my comments always on
my comments your life is crazy yeah I'll
be like you get you Muslim diss you
Muslim that Jesus damn bro all the time
I get difference bro
so usually it's like you either find me
funny or you just don't watch me yeah I
didn't think there was an in-between of
me yeah I watch you but we need you done
yeah yeah yeah yeah I want you probably
I need you all right yo listen you had
your time that's mad you might not get I
couldn't receive a death threat never
mind bro yeah you're strong bro I
couldn't have you tell me you received a
different because I can't be asked for
what can't
welcome
yeah wherever the door now this is a
security everywhere figure this is long
this is long they weren't serious bro
just allow it let's cut me off
the next one is
[Laughter]
the next one is um would you have a
branch out into stand-up comedy
um
do you know it's a little maybe a little
piece of me wants to do it but I don't
know if I can bro why
it's a lot why people choose that career
path to me is
huge bro it's like you have to stand up
and you're responsible for everyone's
like like enjoyment yeah and these men
don't know you either
they don't know they don't know you at
all so I think it's it's a very hard
thing to do so I think I really have to
if I'm ever going to do it I'd need like
a month to prepare I would say it in
front of I would do my my like my skit
or whatever I'm doing in front of my mom
I'll do in front of my friends I'll do
everywhere to see how they find it yeah
and then maybe maybe I'll do it
um but yeah it's a very very very very
difficult profession so I don't know I
think once I'm there if I start at once
I am gone yeah so I was walking
um oh God guys Linda might be darkest
man thank you
yes okay out of the UK scene whose music
do you actually hate okay I wouldn't say
hate but
it's not me
um
actually you know who's okay I'm gonna
kill you guys
sorry bro wait hold on hold on hold on
let me just let me be honest I'm sorry
about your couch I'm sorry so out of the
out of the UK syndridge music do you
actually hate I love everyone's music
very um
UK scene Dave
some trucks stormzy yeah
uh Fredo no
um
some trucks
um I'm just thinking of random people
oh no I didn't I didn't listen to him
we could go all day bro yeah yeah so do
you hate David and cinch no no that's
what that's all I heard
you don't listen to UK rap
devil said I was playing all right cool
that was a I didn't even know that
question was on there that's a very okay
I don't hate anyone all right gang
who also
young guys I like young guys music okay
Peng Tory Lanez
um
[Laughter]
let's just leave UK shall we okay
between trunks Harry off really who
wouldn't you want to share a room with
oh Harry Harry definitely Harry that's
not even a Harry one million not because
Harry's a lovely guy that's one of my
closest you know you notice he's one of
my closest friends yeah yeah I love
Harry no he's one of my closest friends
again
between chunks Harry or Philly who
wouldn't you want to share a room with I
choose Harry I wouldn't want to share a
room with Harry Harry in the space in
the span of five minutes here he would
have fought at 17 times
[Applause]
bowel movements is concerned no he farts
too much so yeah him I think I wouldn't
want I wouldn't sleep I don't think
I wouldn't sleep I'm not yeah yeah in
terms of Vibes someone to talk to is
fantastic love that boy just put but
what comes out of his ass is just it's
just it's just it's a lot yeah yeah
nothing nothing
you guys just need to grow up yeah
yeah cool yeah I think that's all the
questions
that was very nice man oh God wholesome
yeah it was a very wholesome episode
um
slower burner but best finish so far
best pause bro bro we hope to have you
on again
um and again bro well if you're happy
amazing I'd love to be here again so
this is probably my favorite podcast
I've done yeah I've only been on
foreigners third one I can't tell you
because you're not oh yeah oh okay I
thought I can't talk because now and
then fourth is this one okay and we're
your favorite yeah and I'll tell you who
the third one is what we're above them
I would definitely take that props bro
yeah man thank you very much before we
sign off tell them where they can catch
you and reach you and all damn things
there so if they obviously they know but
you know all right cool uh my YouTube's
darkest man my Instagram's darkest man
and that's only the two things I want
you to follow so please if you could can
I edit it can I just say it's going to
be here and here yeah it will be yeah
yeah sorry to make a drop out but your
mask YouTube's going to be here and my
Instagram's gonna be here so let's go
appreciate people all right guys that's
it ladies and gentlemen darkest man
thank you for having us okay I'm at
least top three guest huh well we you're
the third yes so you are definitely top
of three guests yeah by the third guest
yeah okay yeah
yeah nah you're my favorite bro okay
yeah that is mine time that's the okay
what I will say I need to watch all the
episodes back to see who actually the
favorite might I think the best yeah
but one one thing I will say was that
rhyme time was the best segment not even
just guest related yeah just like in the
last 100 episodes yeah bro it was clean
it was clean bro I laughed I nearly
cried my heart was racing I was sweating
we sat I was infested I sat up I sat
down bro
unbelievable Vibes so anyway thank you
for that anyway guys we're gonna wrap it
there uh catch us on Thursday at
patreon.com
[Music]